in this episode I'm going to talk about
ways to associate firebase users with
data and the real time database I'll go
over three different methods and when to
use them and also talk about ways to
keep them secure on the backend but
before we get into that it's important
to go over a couple no sequel database
design best practices if you come from a
sequel background you're used to
designing a database that is completely
centered around relationships and no
sequel we care less about relationships
and more about the efficiency of the
actual query that we're making consider
a database design it has everything
nested under the user ID if you wanted
to loop over just the users and display
their user name you'd also have to load
all the nested data further down the
tree which would become very inefficient
if you have a lot of Records a better
way to handle this is to keep the data
shallow so you only query for the actual
data you need now we can start building
some user relationships with firebase
and angular for the first method works
by nesting a user's items under their
own user ID this is ideal when you're
showing data that's organized by user
for example a Twitter feed here we have
an item service and we're going to
import both the angularfire database and
the angular fire off module then we
create an item class which represents
our data at this point with just one
body string attribute this class will be
returned to us as an angular fire list
observable when we inject the service we
want to subscribe to the angular fire
off state and we'll set the user ID
returned from that off state to the user
ID on the service this allows us to make
queries based on that currently logged
in users ID now that we have the user ID
we can hit the database for the list
that is nested under that user ID if
it's undefined we just return null it's
defined we interpolate it into the path
to the database
if we want to create a new item it's as
simple as pushing another item object
onto this list observable back in the
app we can see that when we create a new
item it's nested under that users user
ID as expected if we log out and log in
with a different user we shouldn't see
any items in the feed which we don't and
if we create a new item with this user
their data is nested under their user ID
essentially separating the data by user
this works great on the front-end but we
also need to secure the backend data
with a firebase database rule in this
example we matched the user ID that the
data is nested under with the actual
auth ID and firebase if it's a match
then we allow the write operation to
take place a second way to associate
users with items is to save the user ID
as an attribute on the item itself this
approach is useful when you need the
Association but you're not querying by
the user for example comments on a blog
post or something similar we can make
this work by modifying three lines of
code first we add a user ID to the item
class then we set that user ID on the
item when it's created then we remove
the user ID from the database path
because we're no longer nesting under
the user ID back in the app we create a
new item and we can see that user ID is
on the item itself and if we create
another item with a different user we
should have a different user ID on that
item but still both items are coming up
in the feed now in firebase we can see
the user ID attribute is on each item
to secure the back end we see if the
existing data in the database has a
matching user ID and we also allow the
right to occur if it's null because that
means the users creating a new item the
third scenario is when you have items
that can be associated with multiple
users in this case we create a
collection of members that are nested
under the item ID and the key for each
member is that users user ID back in the
service will create a new function to
join an item passing at the items key as
an argument the data will be the user ID
for the key set to true we return the
current members as an object observable
then update that observable with the new
data to leave an item we follow the same
basic approach we query for an object
observable with the current user ID and
if it exists we remove it back in the
app we create a new item that defaults
to no members and then we can click the
join button which will add that user ID
to the list of members when we login
with a different user we should see that
they can also add their user ID to this
item
going into firebase we can see that the
members collection on this item it's
updated with the key after each button
is clicked
[Music]
that's it for this episode if you found
the video helpful please like and
subscribe and if you want to support the
channel consider becoming a pro
subscriber at angular firebase comm for
just a few bucks a month you'll get
access to exclusive content as well as
free one-on-one project consulting
thanks for watching and I'll see you
next time
[Music]